the Joe Rogan experience even nerves and
regrows apparently everything in rats I
mean they regrow tendons everything and
I'm gonna try I'm gonna try it locally
here on the bicep see what it does as
soon as I have the water so it seems
like the muscles are growing back though
like slowly but surely
yeah it's 25 pounds I can do eight times
now bicep curls with the right that's a
lot better than it used to be though I
couldn't do five on it yeah not once
Pat Miletich is the same thing same
thing from his neck you know what you
want to hear how crazy Pat's injury was
Pat's disc had deteriorated so badly
that his discs fused themselves he
didn't even realize it his dis fused
themselves he went to the doctor and
they're like well we don't have to fuse
it it or infused itself
well you can't if you talk to him and he
looks at you it's like he hasn't fused
nicked right he's always like Batman
yeah so I guess grappling man I know
they'll blame it on on punching and
kicking but all Danny's injury
everything my rib that was out my last
night's all wrestling is grappling the
rest of point wrestlers are all [ __ ]
up we were talking about Kurt Angle
yesterday it was Olympic gold medalist
fantastic wrestler I mean he's got a
neck that literally is like the size of
my waist but it's his neck so [ __ ] up
both of his arms are tiny and you can
see the atrophy in his arms like his his
arms don't match his neck yeah and you
could tell like you mean obviously you
know better than anybody about neck
injuries guys always like their arms
shrink yeah because they get atrophy
cuts off the nerves
gaile manage it so with image both ways
then yeah well it looks we should pull
up that picture again Jamie see if you
could find it this is Ronda Rousey's
Instagram you could see it I saw him at
the induction at the International
Sports all the famous yeah for Ronda was
there as well and he was sitting first
row but I he was wearing a suit of
course I couldn't tell yeah well he
still looks like a tank yeah but his
[ __ ] neck is ridiculous it's so big
but like look at this
what happened that's us that's great
yeah see look at his arms oh wow yeah
see the size of his neck
I mean his neck it looks like his arms
should be as big as his [ __ ] legs
yeah he just is I mean the guy's been
through hell but look at the [ __ ]
size of his neck have you seen a neck
like that before
shit's crazy that might build a lot of
muscle around it I guess
well yeah it's all [ __ ] up it's been
fused and as yours right yeah for this
fusion front and back
well one splint you know and it opens it
up and then the other ones are fusions
and I have a friend of mine who has five
and he can't move like ah look with me I
have mobility he can't do this again
look to the side a little bit yeah I was
talking to a buddy of mine about a
mutual friend of ours and I didn't
realize that he had done this but he had
went to Germany and got his whole back
fused his whole back is completely
rock-solid few still you know as that
dude who I was looking at for him in the
hospital Don Frye Don Frye has a ten
disc fusion this guy died twice on the
operating table
he had infections the walls were broke
everything man I wasn't in his hospital
he had he lost a lot of weight he had a
big beard and he said check this out he
stood up and from his butt crack all the
way to above his shoulder blades one big
zipper oh damn this fusion dissing your
back that's [ __ ] crazy how many do
you think you're in there Jamie I 13 I
go 15 16 so there's one disc hanging in
there Jesus Jesus take me one one disc
it's got to go why did they say what
fusions if you have a fusion then the
disc below or above are gonna be next
they say become one has this 3308 Bravo
has an artificial disc they put
artificial discs in now these are I wish
I had I couldn't do it at the time yeah
yeah I was in the early but Eddie's got
no problem with it at all it moves great
but that's what I mean bigger for me I
can't do it anymore maybe future you
know without the printing that they do
have the three 3d printing maybe
they can make an exact copy of my spine
and then they go in there it will be
something but that's a scary method to
cut your spine out put a [ __ ]
titanium one in my my daughter my oldest
daughter just told me my ex-wife she's
gonna have to do it at a lower back
she's like two or three fusions they're
gonna need to do what she's gonna do
this grip placement this wall yeah yeah
yeah disc replacement is legit now you
know what Braulio Estima Brazilian
Jujitsu body very famous he's got one in
his neck he was the first guy that I
ever heard about it he [ __ ] his neck
up really bad and then won the world's
with a fucked-up neck and then right
after the world's went and got it
operated on wait what is he doing
because he's from Brazil to do he did it
in Europe because he lives he lives in
England do you ever need will be a I
would let the Germans look at my leg
they're really good for advanced yeah
well you know we got really [ __ ] up
with during the Bush administration they
they put a ban on all stem-cell research
you know they kind of like halted the
brakes on funding stem-cell research
which is really a shame because now
we're realizing stem because they were
they used to think that stem cells had
to do with babies like fetuses they were
thinking people were going to get
abortions just so they could use the
stem cells but now they realize that
mesenchymal stem cells and adults get
stem cells are some of the best and one
of the things they're doing in America
now is sucking fat out of people taking
liposuction and then using the stem
cells from your own body to to
proliferate injured areas I did a two
weeks ago for my knees did you know but
yeah I have no fat though so you have to
take it out of my head bone drill a hole
in there they take the marrow he had to
take the bone marrow and it's
unfortunate because in the fat
apparently have 5 times more the amount
of stem cells than you have in the bone
marrow so people out there that are
fatter pump to hear that they're like
yeah see if I ever get injured I've got
a store of Medicine
[Applause]